star trek picard may be in present day
la but it hasn't forgotten its history
in the stars
deep space nine voyager and even a pair
of influential star trek writers get
shout outs only long time fans will
recognize in picard season 2 episode
three
after picard rafi elnor seven and
gerardi rendezvous with rios aboard the
last surrender they're quickly
intercepted by several confederation
ships that give chase in addition to a
steam runner-class ship previously seen
among the many starships battling the
borg in star trek first contact a nova
class vessel is seen in hot pursuit this
is the first time we've seen that class
of ship since 1997 when it appeared
prominently in the season 5 star trek
voyager cliffhanger and season 6
premiere equinox parts 1 and 2. there
voyager encounters the uss equinox a
science vessel that like voyager has
become trapped in the delta quadrant
after a happy reunion captain janeway
learns that his equinoxes captain ransom
and his crew have been kidnapping and
torturing alien life forms to fuel their
upgraded warp drive it's a nail-biting
adventure and one of the very best of
voyager the nova class starship is a
standout in the episode in a number of
thrilling action sequences and this
return in assimilation is a welcome one
it would appear however that the nova
class in this reality is more than a
mere science vessel and arm to the teeth
for combat
picard's time travel adventure in season
two truly begins in the third episode
assimilation arriving in 2024 picard
seven of nine gerardi rafi and rios
first set foot in the past in los
angeles and long time trek fans will
note this is not the first time a star
trek episode has gone back in time to
contemporary la the two-part star trek
voyager episode futures end likewise saw
the voyager crew travel back to los
angeles this time to 1996 the same year
the episode aired assimilation includes
a montage of iconic la locations but not
the ones you might expect rather than
show us the hollywood sign or the sunset
strip the episode shows us the santa
monica pier and griffith observatory two
locations are played a major part in
future's end the periods where the crew
of voyager first arrive in the city and
remark on the unusual attire of the era
the observatory is where tuvak and tom
paris go to get information and where
they meet sarah silverman's character
rain robinson
what do you do here
we watch the skies
for what given all the famous la spots
that assimilation could have shown to
orient the viewer these two seem too
specific to be anything but a reference
to the classic time travel two-parter
coincidence or not it just so happens
that picard and his new crew find
themselves in 2024 the same year that
captain cisco dr bashir and lieutenant
dax time traveled to in the deep space
nine episode
past tense that two-part time travel
episode has become a beloved classic
among trekkies for its haunting
portrayal of what was then a future 30
years away the crux of that episode
revolved around cisco and bashir being
trapped in a homeless encampment called
a sanctuary district in san francisco
cisco and bashir are forced to stay in a
closed-off area designed to keep the
homeless from encroaching on the city
because they have no id or paperwork
while there they get caught up in a
historic civilian uprising called the
bell riots which were said to have
occurred in september of 2024
do you ever hear the bell riots
vaguely it is one of the most violent
civil disturbances in american history
and it happened right here the riots
began after the unjust killing of a man
named gabriel bell among other sanctuary
residents in assimilation raffian seven
appeared to materialize within a
sanctuary district in the very same year
of course the fact that this one is in
los angeles seems to show us that the
government-run homeless encampments
extends beyond the bay area in
california it doesn't explain however
how seven and rafi seem to have no
trouble leaving the district in past
tense the armed guards patrolling its
borders barred cisco and bashir from
exiting
the last surroundings transporters must
not be operating correctly because when
rios beams down to los angeles he
doesn't materialize safely instead he
beams into mid-air and falls nearly two
stories to the ground seriously injuring
himself
however it's where he materializes and
gets us our next easter egg rios lands
on the sidewalk outside of a los angeles
establishment called the tipton brothers
delhi a google search for this location
yields no results and that would make
sense as the delhi's name is a clear nod
to scott and david tipton two comic book
writers who have produced several
stories for the star trek franchise at
idw publishing the tipton's work for
star trek includes titles such as
klingons blood will tell and deep space
nine fool's gold this reference could be
particularly relevant to this season of
picard as the pair also authored the
doctor who crossover story assimilation
squared which featured the borg and the
five issue alternate reality comic
mini-series mirror images
landing from a two-story fall didn't get
rios a nice meal from tipton's deli
instead it sends him to a local clinic
with serious injuries including some
broken bones the clinic in question run
by dr teresa seems to specialize in
caring for those without identification
although the doctor is happy to help
rios off the books when he insists on at
the hospitals it's still not safe for
him to be there and rios makes for a
quick exit after getting treated however
it's a little too late as homeland
security arrives for a raid in the
facility before he can slip out
attempting to stay behind to help dr
teresa rios is instead taken into
custody by the police the officer who
curves him as for id and rios admits
that he doesn't have any
i don't know if you're stupid
let me guess no uhc card no id
i'm gonna go with stupid fans of deep
space nine will remember this line from
the time travel two partner past tense
when cisco and bashir arrive in 2024
they have no identification just like
rios and are stopped by police who ask
for the same uhc card all right let's
see some logo logo id
identification
uhc cut though it's never said what the
card is it's clearly used for
identification in this version of 2024.
without one it sounds like rios is
getting a one-way ticket to a sanctuary
district just like cisco
as rafi gets acquainted with her
surroundings and the homeless encampment
she eyes a massive banner on a building
across the street that advertises an
apparent mission to europa one of
jupiter's many moons the banner reads
the new interplanetary explorers and
includes the classic star trek tagline
to boldly go while this could be a
poster for a new movie or tv show in
2024 we're guessing this is a nod to the
star trek universe's early space
exploration efforts though they've yet
to materialize in real life in star trek
history humanity began exploring other
planets as early as the 2020s in the
star trek voyager episode one small step
the crew discovers a space module that
had launched from earth in 2032 and
gotten lost on its way to mars in the
episode it suggested that this wasn't
earth's first interplanetary mission if
the banner seen by rafi is any
indication it seems like by 2024
humankind already has a mission to
europa on its mind
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]